entraîné par le joueur et animateur
diplômé de la fédération française des
échecs claude chiron ses élèves de cm2
ça donne une fois par semaine un cours
un peu originale des parties d'échecs
après une présentation théorique sur un
échiquier murale les élèves se lancent
en duo une initiative qui semble plaire
à ses enfants j'adore cgt pense que je
les fais depuis que je suis toute toute
petite elle jette mon grand-père j'adore
mais parfois quand je ne sais pas quoi
faire si stressant parce que j'aime pas
trop perdre c'est très important de
faire ce genre de jeu surtout qu'ils ne
sont plus habitués à jouer
enfin moins habitués à jouer à des jeux
de société et surtout des jeux de
société de ce niveau qui sont vraiment
complexe un jeu qui possède de nombreux
bénéfices il invite les élèves à la
réflexion la stratégie ou encore la
mémorisation c'est un jeu des stratégies
et aussi ses des réflexions tu dois
réfléchir avant de jouer et du coup ça
t'aide aussi dans dans les devoirs ou à
l'école parce que trouve on s'amuse
beaucoup avec nos amis ou des bons jours
ensemble je me connais ça nous aider
avec les chiens nous concentrer quand
vous apprenez et ça c'est très important
que vous apprenez le jeu d'échecs en
milieu élémentaire
lorsque vous arrivez au collège eh bien
vous avez beaucoup plus de facilité donc
à mémoriser et à
comprendre les choses certains élèves
sur trend victor peut selon ses
camarades faire un échec et mat en
quatre coups dit le coup du berger
espoirs de la classe il est souvent
sollicité par l'animateur pour enseigner
aux autres il a vraiment un à caution
qui lui permet donc de d'apprendre aux
autres élèves et je compte sur lui parce
que ce garçon il met déjà dans cette
activité pour montrer vous le 22 mars
prochain les élèves raconteront à
domicile les champions de france
sortants lors du championnat scolaire
académique d'échec